الفعاليه الناجحه اللي على مستوى راقي
يليق من مكانه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
انا اتحدى انها تربي حاجتين 10% ما في
بنيه تحتيه
ال ip
[موسيقى]
هذا سقراط من اذاعه 8 والعمر الجريسي
استضيف قاده التحول وقاده الاعمال وقاده
الراي وسوف معهم على المستجدات ومستهدفات
رؤيه السعوديه 2030 ضيف حلقه اليوم هو
الاستاذ زكي حسنين مؤسس ورئيس مجلس اداره
شركه بنش بارك لتنظيم الفعاليات
اصدقاءنا القدام يمكن متغير عليهم شويه
وسقراط وفجاه صاروا يشوفون قيادات من
القطاع الخاص وشركات خاصه واحيانا يكون
جزء من الحلقه عن تجربتهم الشخصيه همم
البعض يعتقد انه هذه مثلا حلقات مدفوعه ما
في ولا حلقه مدفوعه كاس السقراط ما في
حلقه السابقه ولا حلقه مستقبليه حتكون
بمقابل مادي احنا مهتمين بتوثيق الرؤيا
وكل همم تجربه سواء تجربه جهاز حكومي او
جهاز خاص او شخص بتساعد على هذا الموضوع
بنحرس اننا نستفيد منها اليوم على سبيل
المثال هو عامل في قطاع الترفيه من 2003
رحله شهدت المرحله ما قبل الرؤيا وما
بعدها في قطاع الترفيه اللي هو احد
القطاعات الحيويه في رؤيه السعوديه 20 30
فاخذنا القصه والتجربه شفنا ايش كانت
التحديات وكيف المشهد قبل وايش يختلف
اليوم تكلمنا على موضوع تحدي الاستدامه
التشريعات البني التحتيه تجربه العميل همم
كواليس اول حفله موسيقيه بجمهور
مختلط همم وكيف كانت ترتيبات لها وايش
النتيجه همم من هذه الحفله وتكلمنا على
همم هوامش ربحيه هذا القطاع وغيرها من
التفاصيل همم اللي اتركم تسمعونها في
الحوار حياك الله ابو احمد تشرفنا نورتنا
اهلا وسهلا فيك وانا ما تتصور قد ايه مدى
سعادتي اني انا اكون همم الحاجه اللي انا
احبها الله يسعدك
ودي اعرف قصتك مع قالوا لي انك انت بعدي
مع البليله وشي زي كذا والله شوفي اذا
تبغانا واحنا صغار احنا عيال مكه نشتغل اي
شيء اوكي بس انا يعني همم
طال عمرك انا من سكان مكه
ووالدي كان همم بايع خبز او عندنا مخبز
وعندنا محل فول وما بعدنا كثيره
تربينا في مكه الحمد لله واشتغلنا كل شيء
اشتغلنا في الحج واشتغلنا في العمره وبعنا
بليله ما ما ما ما ما ما ما كذب من قال لك
بس احنا صغار في الحاره
ايس كريم بليله
اتزوج واحد جزاه الله خير قال لي اخوان
مارتي
مدير شركه ليموزين في المطار
وعسى ما خرب الموضوع هذا الزواج لا والله
بالعكس اعتقد شكلهم شدو في قالوا هذا كذاب
احمد احنا سعداء جدا بقبورك الدعوه وحابين
يعني نحكي معك بصفتك مؤسس ورئيس مجلس
اداره شركه بنش بارك شركه تعمل في الترفيه
من عام 2003 هذا بالنسبه لي خلاني اقول
فرصه لقينا الشخص اللي يقدر يحكيني عن
القطاع قبل وبعد الرؤيا هذا تركيز بوت
كاستقرام ايش اللي يخليك تدخل قطاع
الترفيه 2003
خاص طول حياتي من يوم ما تخرجت من الجامعه
تقريبا انا اشتغل في عده شركات كنت مشغول
يعني لازم يكون في جزئيه من شغلي حاجه
تهتم بالعلاقات العامه بالتسويق
بالفعاليات بكل الشركات اشتغلتها اخر شركه
كنت شغال فيها كانت تستعمل في الازياء
تمام فانا طبعا كنت على راس الشركه هذه
فلازم نحنا نطلع اربع مرات في السنه عشان
نعمل باينغ للملابس لما تروح تعمل باين
يعني انت بتتفرج على فاشن شوش تمام فانا
تقريبا اغلب من مصممين العالميين انا
دخلت عروض ازياءهم فكنت بحكم اني انا يعني
الشركه اللي احنا فيها شركه ما شاء الله
تبارك الله عليها باع كبير في الموضوع
طريقه التعامل مع مصمم الازياء مع عارضات
الازياء مع السرعه في انها العارضه تطلع
على طول تشيل اللبس الاول عشان تلبس
اللبسه الثانيه
في الكلام ده وكبر في راسي
ومريت بالايام الا اني انا قررت في يوم من
الايام اني انا اترك القطاع الخاص
واستجه اني انا اكون صاحب عمل وهذا قرار
صراحه تبغى الحكم قرار مره صعب كنت انا
متزوج عندي ثلاثه اطفال ذاك الوقت
وما كان يعني عندي راس مال
فا- همم يعني فكرت قلت يا ولد يمكن اسلم
طريقه ما يبغى لها راس مال هو انك انت
تاخذ مكتب وتشتغل في موضوع التسويق
الاعلاني
بس ايش علاقه المعرض الازياء بالتسويق
الاعلاني يعني لازم نوضحوا اساس يسعدك
لا ابدا اللي يسعدني اني انا تعلمت اشياء
مره كثيره اوكي تمام تعلمت تعلمت كيف حركه
الحشود تمام كيف عمليه الهسبتلتي لازم
تدخل تمام في وقت محدد يكون لك محلك موجود
ما تجلس تدور على كرسيك تمام بعد كده
الموضوع انك انت همم الوقت المحدد اللي
تبدا فيه الفعاليه تمام طريقه تنظيم
الفعاليه من ايتو زد او ما تنسى يعني احنا
اغلب الاماكن اللي كنا نروحها كنا نروح
ميلانو وكلنا نروح باريس وهدول الناس يعني
لهم باع مره كبيره
يعني احنا نعتبرهم يعني يمكن من الناس
ملوك الفعاليات في العالم
فلما طلعت ايامها كنت طبعا ايامها الازياء
كنت انا ااا يعني لازم نعلن تمام فكنت
نعلن على يوني بول نعلين على الميديا اللي
كانت موجوده في الزمان ذاك او الجرائد
والمجلات
وبحكم علاقتي كان في مجله مشهوره للازياء
تمام تواصلت مع صاحبها لقيت انه هو ما
عنده
مكتب في السعوديه هو شركه لبنانيه اخذتها
منه بالاضافه اني انا كان في عندي مواقع
اخرى اخذ فيها اعمده الكبيره
وبالصدفه البحث كمان كان في مركز تجاري
بين انشاء وكان في اول ايس كريم تكون في
جده
اخذ صناعه اللوح داخل المول
وقال لي يا اخي صلاح ايش رايك انا ابغى
اقلب المكان ده الى دخل اعلاني بحكم اني
انا عندي صاله التزلج وقال لي شفت الصاله
في لندن كيف كانت في اللوجو على الثلج
واشياء زي كده والله اعجبتني الفكره رحت
لواحد صديق لي كان يشتغل في الملاعب
يبيعوا الاعلانات في الملاعب قلت له كده
كده قال لي والله فكره مره كويسه
هذا تقريبا
2,000
فبدانا الحمد لله الرجال انبسط مننا جبنا
له دخل مره كويس انا تعرفت على الشركات
اللي هي تصرف في مجال الاعلانات اللي هي
الشركات اللي هي اللي فيها المعلنه الاف
ام سي جي ولا شيء الكبار
وقتها الحمد لله الراجل هذا ربنا انعم
عليه اخذ مركز ثاني اعطاني هو صار في عندي
ثلاثه ااا
مراكز تجاريه دخلوا علينا هوامير السوق
الموضوع اللي هو مول
في المملكه بدات انا
حاجه مره صغيره انسحبت من الموضوع ده
ودخلت في موضوع لاني صار لي معرفه
باسماء الشركات اللي هي بتصرف في موضوع
الدارك في ماركت
دخلت في موضوع الدرس بدنا نعمل في الاسواق
التجاريه سامسونج في السوبر ماركت بدا
موضوع
الحمد لله بطريق
بعد كده
اكل اللي هو في السوبر ماركت اكل عطور
بروموشن حق
اللي هي تمام
فالموضوع هذا كان مره كويس وكان يعني شغله
مره كبير بعد كده
صار في اعلانات داخل السوبر ماركت اللي هي
الهيدرس اللي فوق همم الشمس
دخلت فيها
يا دوب يا دوب حطيت رجلي جوك الكبار
وسحب السوق من تحت رجلي
بعد كده ربنا اكرمني بحاجه وانا تصورت
انها هي هذه الانطلاقه الكبيره بس صدفه
البحته
جاءتني مواقف المسجد النبوي الشريف
انا عاد وياما كنت صغير شفت نفسي ايش دقه
دقه 100 مليون يا ولد حطيت رجلي شلت فلوسي
اللي فوق تحت كلها دخل سويت اللوح جوه
المواقف
الشيء الوحيد اللي ما عرفته وقتها حاجتين
انه الشركات الكبيره المالتي ناشينال في
عندها بروسيجر انها لا تعلن في المناطق
السياسيه او الدينيه
هذه الصدمه اللي ماكو تعرفها وثانيا
اللي هي ال ال ال ال الميديا باينغ هاوسس
الكبيره
اكلت خساره جامده نزلت
يملك الحق هذا وكان يعني الرجل دور لقى
وصلته له سبحان الله فانت ما نجحت لانه
الشركات العالميه ما تعلن في اماكن دينيه
والشركات المحليه في وسطاء عمالقه
الايام اس تي سي وقفوا معي اشتروا مني
وغيره
قعدت اتفرج على لوحي زي اللي عندكم بطيخ
طال عمرك في الحلقه الي خمج مره مره نزلت
على الزيرو نزلت على الزيرو بعد ما رجعت
عالزيرو نعم
رجعت السوق طبعا الحمد لله بعد ما يعني
كنت وفي مع الموظفين ودفعت رواتبهم وبعت
الاشياء الممتلكات ساعات اشياء ام العيال
اعطتني كم طقم ذهب بعنا الحمد لله المكتب
شغال ف جاء الى ذهني موضوع اني انا يا ولد
ليش ما احاول اني ارجع للشركه اللي انا
كنت شغال فيها واقول لهم اعمل لكم عرض
ازياء
وهنا يجيك الموضوع اللي لازم شركه الاقمشه
شركه الاقمشه والازياء اللي كنت شغال فيها
والله عجبتهم الفكره بحكم انهم عندهم هاي
فاشن
قالوا لي طيب تقدر تطلع ترخيص
وهنا السؤال الصعب قلت لهم والله على الله
يعني تقريبا تقريبا
ان شاء الله خير والله يعني جلست حاولت
رحت لاصدقاء انا لحبايبنا في اللي هم
اصحاب الاختصاص كلهم قالوا ما نقدر ما
نقدر ترخيص والله قلت يا ولد مالك الا تدق
الباب جمعيه خيريه
والله رحت لجمعيه الخيريه طرحت عليهم
الفكره قالوا لي طيب نحن ايش مردود انا
قلت لهم نحن اللي جينا تمام حنعطيكم يعني
منه شيء بالنسبه للجمعيه قولوا لي خلاص ما
تشيل هم نحن ناخذ موضوع الترخيص والله ما
قصروا الجماعه راحوا وقالوا الله طرح
البركه جابه وليد الترخيص
الحمد لله اديك الايام عشان كمان حسن
النيه كان في
همم شركه ما اعرف هل اقول سلامتك
الايام همم قوارير سنويه يتم ال- اا
المزاد عليها وترجع حصتها الى جمعيه
الجمعيه بالكامل ما تاخذ شركه ايفانا اي
شيء والله توكلنا على الله بدانا نشتغل في
موضوع ان احنا ناخذ همم
الخطوه الثانيه رحت استاجرنا قاعه مهمه في
جده
ورتبناه امورنا لقينا الحمد لله عارضات
ازياء طبعا عرض ازياء ما يدخلوا رجال ولا
انا ابشرك يعني حتى الباكستيج كان رن
تم تدريبهم تمام من قبل الشركه اللي هي
كانت حتكون
ماسكه موضوع الفاشن
جينا يوم
عرض الازياء
قاعه الافراح جاد قالوا لي نحنا ما نقدر
نسويها وانا بدي خلاص دفعت فلوس ورتبت
اموري وخلصت كل شيء ليش ما يقدرون قالوا
والله
ممكن انك انت تستبدل الموضوع عارضات
الازياء بانك انت تلبس الازياء على
مونيكانز والناس تدخل وتفرج وتعشوا يضربوا
الباب
تخيل انت الصدمه اللي شاتني في ديك اللحظه
يهديكم يرضيكم حاولت جهدي تمام
قالوا لي كاتوك
ومودل تمشي عليها لا يمكن
والله تعرف بحكم يعني سبحان الله الخبره
والهام من عند الله سبحانه وتعالى قلت لهم
مافي كاتبه
كلمت المسؤوله جوا قلت لها لبس البنات
ازياء ياخذوا وكراوند حول الطاولات
وجدو خلاص بداوا الناس يجوا قالت لي طيب
خلاص
البنت تاخذ لفه كامله تدخل عندك تلبسيها
اللبسه الثانيه والحمد لله يعني كانت فكره
مره حلوه
وتقبلوها الناس وسوينا المزاد على
القاروره وبيعت بمبلغ مره كويس لدرجه انه
جمعيه الجمعيه الخيريه هذه سعره كل مره
يقولوا لي تكفى اذا عندك شيء ترى نحن معك
وهذا كان بالنسبه لي يعني يعني حاجه هذه
رجعتك لعالم التنظيم
وعرفتني ايش اللي يصير ويصير اللي ما يصير
لا تكون اولويز ابتمستك لانه ممكن فديك
اللحظه وفي ديك الايام يجيك
مراقب بلديه يوقفك راحت مليون اثنين مليون
ترى الفعاليات كانت ذكريات ما هي بالمبالغ
الى الحين الناس يشوفوها
فالحمد لله مشينا بالموضوع ده وخلاص
الحمد لله
بس الحمد لله اني انا انبسطت انه الجمعيه
استفادت صار في عندي
انا لما ابغي شيء اروح للجمعيه دي وصار
فيه تراست
بعدها طبعا بدانا ندخل في موضوع اني انا
اروح على شركات جاتني فكره شركات السيارات
حق السيارات
هذه الاشياء دخل اطلاق المنتجات جديده
لونشنغ حق مول اشتغلنا يعني سنتين ثلاث
سنوات في هذا الموضوع الى انه جاءتني فكره
اني انا ابدا ادخل في موضوع المؤتمرات
والمنتديات ورش العمل
همم
فالحمد لله الله اكرمنا اخذنا منتدى
المشروبات كان هذا منتدى مره مهم لانه تحت
همم رعايه جامعه الدول العربيه لانه يعني
تقريبا شبه عالمي والحمد لله تمام 2013
همم
جاءت الغرفه التجاريه
تبنت الموضوع ده صار في عندي حاجه ثانيه
غير الجمعيه الخيريه الغرفه التجاريه
بعد كده الحمد لله اللي هو كان ديك الايام
بالنسبه لي انا حلم اني انا اقدر انظم
منتدى جدا الاقتصادي لانه منتدى جده
الاقتصادي فهذيك الايام المنتدى الرياضه
الاقتصادي تعتبر من اهم المنتديات في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه لانه هيقول لك
انه انا بعد ما خلصت جدا الاقتصادي كنت
بحاول اني اخذ مبتدا جدا مبتدا الرياضه
الاقتصادي والحمد لله اخذته السنه
ههه
يعني حتى في عندي في الشركه يعني
الحمد لله ما شاء الله فالحمد لله توفق
نادي كالايام كان طبعا همم
مجلس اداره الغرفه التجاريه العامه
المرحوم صالح كامل
وانبسط كثير انه انا ابني معي وماخذ جزء
كبير من العمل
همم بعدها يعني كان نقله صراحه يعني عملنا
نقله في همم المنتدى الاقتصادي
عملنا طبعا شاشه بانوراميه حطينا كل ثقل
انا في الموضوع ده لانه قلنا ان شاء الله
هذه انطلاقه ان احنا نعرف من هي بنت مالك
والحمد لله توفقنا بعدها الله يرحمه ويحسن
اليه برده دخلنا في منافسه مهمه جدا اللي
هي مهرجان جده غير هذا المواسم السياحيه
ما كان في غير مهرجان جدا غير وهذا تمام
وكانها
الحمد لله سوينا برضو فعاليه جدا جميله
انبسطوا الناس فيها ااا
جبنه جبنه فريق من المانيا عمل اكروبات
على على الاستيج عملنا تريدي ما بينك هذه
تقنيات كانت الساعه هدوبها داخله السوق
بعد كده
كان في حفلات غنائيه ولكنها طبعا همم
اسواق همم اللي هي البروموشن حق الاسواق
همم العاب همم او رقصات شعبيه يعني كانت
هي هذه تماما العاب بحريه جاك عليها رسائل
الواتساب تاريخيه
ايه الحمد لله بعد انت خلاص منتدى جده
الاقتصادي دخلت على مهرجان جده غير طيب في
اللحظه هذه وش اتعرف نفسك انت انت شركه
ايش انا شركه فعاليات فعاليات فعاليات
فممكن اقتصاديه ممكن ترفيهيه تمام
اليوم نحن في كان معرض في جده او في
الرياض يسموه البيك فايف
هادي انا احنا كنا نجلس نحفه علشان ناخذ
في اداره حدود اليوم والله ولله الحمد
والمنه
انضمنا معرض الكتاب اكبر من البيك 5 بثلاث
مرات
هو يعني معرض مالتي ناشند يعني في العالم
كله في دبي
[موسيقى]
في عصر رقمي متغير باستمرار المواكبه هي
اساس النجاح ولاننا رواد المستقبل الرقمي
نوظف خبراتنا وقدراتنا لنمكن نبتكر في
تبني احدث التقنيات وتوفير الحلول بكفاءه
سلوشن سبايسي
[موسيقى]
ولا ما ارجع ابو احمد للمرحله هذيك بعد
تقريبا ان تتكلم الان على حدود عشر سنوات
او اكثر 10 سنوات وانت شغال ما فيها ثلاثه
الى 13 14 15
يضحكون علي ليش يقولون
تكافح في موضوع ما حيصير ما حيصير واحد
فيهم قال لي الله يعني ههه
ههه بس في العشر سنوات هذه ودي اعرف ايش
اهم التحديات اللي كانت تواجهك يعني شيء
تقول انت يعني موجود في اي احد يعمل ذاك
القطاع ما كان موجود شيء اسمه ترخيص
فعاليات ما كان ما في ما في فتوح لا وزاره
التجاره
الاعلام عندها
ترخيص كان يطلع من الحاكم الاداري للمنطقه
فهذا تمام عشان تاخذ من الترخيص هذا من
الحاكم الاداري يعني انت لازم تلف على 14
اداره حكوميه عشان توافق
يعني طيب قطاع ما في ما في تراخيص
والفاعليه يمكن تتقفل بزياره موظف وشو
يصبرك 10 سنوات
شوف الصراحه تبغى العمل هذا ممتع ممتع
ممتع لانه انت يعني
قبل النوم اشيك تويتر واشوف ردود
التعليقات الناس على الفعليه هذا بالنسبه
للتكييف فقط
هو
في تحديات كبيره
ونهايه سعيده لانك انت اولا هيكون العميل
اذا ربنا وفقك وسويت فعاليه ممتازه لعمل
حكم مبسوط الناس مبسوطين وهذا حقلك اياه
احنا الان ان شاء الله لما ندخل فيما
موضوع بعد الرؤيه
فهو ممتع
ووووو وما يبغى له راس مال كبير
ومردوده بالنسبه لي انا مبسوط ما دام انا
مبسوط وعيالي مبسوطه
ههه
جاءت الرؤيا 2016 اعلن عن همم رؤيه
السعوديه 20 30 وكانت مفاجاه الكثير من
الناس انهم يقرون
بقطاع الترفيه والثقافه ولي العهد في
مقابله مع تركي الدخيل يقول احنا نفتقر او
نفتقد لخيارات التنفيذ والثقافه اللي
بتحسن جوده حياه الناس هذا كلام 2016 انت
لما سمعت الكلام هذا ولما شفته مكتوب في
وثيقه الرؤيه سعود اللي جاك طبعا ما تتصور
مدى الفرحه الكبيره اللي غمرتني انا
وتقريبا يمكن ناس كثير
المملكه بس انا بدي احب اعرج على موضوع
مهرجان جد التاريخيه لانه هذا المهرجانات
هذا المهرجان كانت في
2004 2013
هذا حق الفرق
[ضحك]
فمهرجان جده التاريخيه هذا طبعا ولله
الحمد انا يعني اعتز في كثير جدا وانا
اشكر من قلبي صراحه اللي اعطاني الثقه
تمام لعمل المهرجان هذا تمام يعني كان همم
سمو الامير خالد الفيصل الله يحفظه او سمو
الامير مشعل بن ماجد محافظ جده بالاضافه
الى الغرفه التجاريه والى امانه المدينه
جده يعني او لوني مهمه جدا مهمه جدا مهمه
صراحه يعني شوفوا جدا التاريخيه كانت اكيد
انت زرتها هي منطقه تاريخيه فيها
ازقه وشوارع وكانت تقريبا
احنا قضينا ايام وليالينا نحن ننظفها طال
عمرك من اشياء مره كثير مره كثير فوق ما
تتصور يعني منطقه كان يعني لو تسمح لي
اقول لك كانت تمشي والفئران جنبك
اشتغلنا نظفنا في ايران نظفناها من
المخالفين النظام الاقامه
الين قدرنا نحنا لانه هو انت اليوم تبغى
تجيب الناس اللي ساكنين في شمال جده
والمدن المحيطه بشده الى منطقه جده
التاريخيه والحمد لله تمكنا ولله الحمد
في النسخه الاولى لمهرجان جده التاريخيه
اللي كانت 10 ايام ان احنا دخلنا مليون
زائر في شوارع ضيقه وهنا نحن تعلمنا اداره
الحوشود
نحن وانا وابنائي
العاملين معنا وكان على راسهم الله يحفظه
ابني محمد
احنا من حظنا الجميل تمام كنا نعملها
مرتين نعمل في الشتاء 10 ايام ونعمل حاجه
في رمضان والعيد كان اسمها رمضان انا كذا
وعيدنا كده فديك الفتره كانت
الحكومه متواجده في جده وكان ما في شيء
يصير غيرنا فنحنا ولله الحمد ولله الحمد
جميع موظفين الدوله زارونا وامراء المناطق
لانه كان برضو
همم
يروح العاده وبعدين يجونا في زياره
واختهم المهرجان تمام بزياره غاليه جدا
على نفسي هي زياره الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز الى المنطقه التاريخيه
يعني همم كان جدا سعيد صراحه وفي لي صوره
انا اعتز فيها جدا
مع مع خادم الحرمين الشريفين
ومع سمو سيدي كمان حتى كنا يعني باللبس
الحجازي انا ولدي
الحمد لله تعلمنا من المهرجان هادي اشياء
مره كثيره طبعا المهرجان هذا لا تعتقد ان
هو زي دي الايام يعني ترى هذا كان هو ببسط
نبيع بليله واكل اكل حجازي وكان يعني
برده كنا نجيب ازياء من مناطق المملكه كنا
نجيب اكلات شعبيه من من من من من المناطق
اللي هي على على ساحل البحر الاحمر لانها
تقريبا الاكل مشابه
اللي بعده وفرق شعبيه وطبعا ووو
وبعدين جات الفكره حقت الاستاندر كوميدي
شويه بس نحن طبعا من اول مهرجان جد
التاريخيه الى نهايته ونحنا نستقبل انا
وابني والمسؤولين
ناس ادعوا علينا احنا
جبنا الناس وسوينا اختلاط يعني انا شفت
النار خلاص شفت جهنم قدامي من كثر ما دعوا
علينا جزاهم الله خير تمام ما شاء الله
الزوار مبسوطين فوق ما تتصور مبسوطين نحن
كان
اخوي عمر او ابن عمر
عوائل اهل جده اللي هم طلعوا منها بس بيت
جدهم موجود معروف بيت فلان بيت فلان فاذا
جد موجود كان جد انه الجد
بالاسره داخلين علينا المهرجان وتعال شوف
البكاء وانواع من الجد والجده والاب اذا
الاب اذا كان ابوه وامه متوفيين عملنا
الحراك اجتماعي جميل
جميل جدا
والحمد لله كذلك نحن في الفتره هديك تم
تسجيل جدا التاريخيه في اليونسكو
وهذا يعني عمل انا صراحه اسعدني جدا اني
انا كان لي جزء بسيط انا وشركتي وابنائي
بانا نحنا
تم تسجيل جدا التاريخيه انا سعيد جدا انه
جميع مسؤولين المملكه توجهوا انا كانت
سعادتي ما تتصور قد ايش يوم ما اعلن سمو
سيدي بعمل اداره جدا التاريخيه لاني انا
حسيت نفسي اني انا لي جزء انا نظفت الشارع
ده انا جبت الناس دول لفت نظر الناس كلهم
للمنطقه دي
وهذا يعني نعمه ربنا اكرمني فيها ولو بسال
ابو احمد ايش اكثر شيء استفدتوه بعد
التجربه ايش بكون شوف صراحه تبغى الحق
يعني عشان لا اقول لك انه احنا ما شاء
الله تبارك الله مره مطلعين ولكن هي دائما
ولله الحمد الله بيكرمنا بالصدفه تاريخيه
تعلمنا في اشياء مره كثيره نحن جبنا الناس
على شارع على منطقه ترى هي كلها على بعضها
كيلو متر تمام دخلناهم تجربه زائر جدا
جميله الناس
دخلوا وصلوا باريحيه لانه صراحه انت تبغى
الحق يعني
اللجنه الامنيه كانت واقفه معانا واقفه
جميله يعني احنا كنا الناس بيجوا من شمال
جده عشان تدخل جده التاريخيه يعني مشوار
تمام يعني كان في تسهيل كبير بوصول الزائر
الى المنطقه نحن رتبنا كل
الاراضي الفاضيه المحيطه بجده التاريخيه
وسفتناها وعملنا باركينج جبنا اكثر من 30
عربات جولف عشان ننقل الناس من المواقف
الى الى داخل المدينه التاريخيه اتعلمنا
كيف ندير حشود ان احنا ندخلهم ونخرجهم
بدون اي مشكله يعني كذلك نحن تعلمنا كيف
نصنع تجربه ترفيهيه متكامل
فديك الفتره
اتت رؤيه سمو سيدي الامير محمد بن سلمان
الله يحفظك
[موسيقى]
الامور طيبه ما كنا نحتاج يعني رؤيه قطاع
الترفيه عشان نشتغل قاعدين تضموه فعاليات
وقاعدين يعني تسوون كل شيء بدون ما
تحتاجون انه يكون في هيئه للترفيه ولا
يكون فيه رؤيه للترفيه وايش الفرق معكم
ابدا احنا كنا نشتغل برضا الوالدين
لك ممكن يجيك واحد مراقب موقفك
يعني كانت تقوم وتمشي الامور تمام بتوفيق
الله تمام
ومحاولتنا نحن جاهدا ان احنا ما نخرج من
القانون اللي ما هو موجود ترى ما كان في
قانون
المراقب هذا اللي جاي يقتل قانون حق راسه
كده
واحد من اقارب لما كان يعني
نظره شويه مختلفه فكان يقول يعني ليش
نحتاج
هيئه الترفيه وقتها كان هيئه الثقافه قبل
ما تتاسس الوزاره كان يعني مستغرب من
البلد في هذه الفتره 2016 في تحديات
اقتصاديه وفي اولويات التعليم والسكان
البطاله اشياء كثيره
وفي نفس الوقت كانت نسوي هيئه الترفيه مش
القيمه يعني قبل ما اتكلم على ايش اللي
اختلف تخيل ناقش ليش البلد يحتاج هياثر
فيه يعني انا بكتبش كلام
لواحد اسمه عبد الرحمن الناصر همم في
جولايا 2016 كتب مقاله يقول كانت مدن
المملكه حتى نهايه التمرينات تعيش حراك
الفنيه الرائعه وكان جمهور السعودي يجد
امامه خيارات ترفيهيه متنوعه تلبي
احتياجاته لكن مع بدايه التسعينات توقفت
الامور واخر حفله غنائيه في الرياض مثلا
في عام 1992 اما بقيه المدن فما عاد في
حفلات في الانديه الرياضيه واختصر الحرائق
الغنائي على مهرجانات في مشرح المفتاح
فابها وحفلات صيف جدا وحتى الاثنين هذا
يتوقفوا وهرب الفنانون السعوديون ومعهم
جمهورهم الى عواصم خليجيه
حملت بذكاء غايه الحفلات وتخصصت في تنظيم
امسيات لفنانين السعوديين يحضرها جمهور
سعودي
انا اعتبر شاهد على هذا الشيء انا من
مواليد
احد الملك فيصل اقول لعمري ولا
لسه شباب ما شاء الله هذا من مواليد 1961
فانا يعني انا انا شفت كل شيء يعني انا
شفت لو ما كان في في جده سينما
تمام شفت حفلات كان كان كان نحنا كل عيد
كان كل عمده او العماره كانت تطلب من عمد
من العمد انهم هم يعملوا حاجه اسمها
البرزه اللي هيعمله مكان مخصص في في مدخل
الحي يجوا الناس يعيده على بعض وفي الليل
يكون في في غنى هذا حضرناه احنا
وحظرت يوم ما انك انت ما تقدر يعني ما
تقدر تسوي
رقصه شعبيه ممنوع
وحضرت العهد الجميل هذا اللي انا فيه الان
ليش هذا الشيء تعتبر مهمه يعني بعض الناس
يعتبرها مو بقولوا ما يخالف عن النظره
الفكريه في الموضوع خلينا نقول حتى لو هي
جيده مو بلاه خلينا نخلص التعليم الصحه
السكن الوظائف بعدين افكر ترفيه وثقافه
تماما انا في وجهه نظري مو لان انا اعتبر
مستفيد من هذا القط لا بس انا الان بالذات
حتكلم كم مواطن اليوم بدي انا اسالك سؤال
اليوم انت ولله الحمد
اخوك الصغير بيروح المدرسه يتعلم ليش لانه
مرتاح نفسيا
نحن كلنا نروح المدرسه غصبا عليها لانه
ملل
اليوم قطاع الترفيه غير
الكلشهر بالكامل اليوم نحن ولله الحمد
تمام
الناس مبتسمه ترى كنت لما تطلع فوق واحد
يقول لك تشبك انت تعرفني لما انت تسلم
عليه يقول لك ليش سلمت علي اليوم الناس
مبتسموا لبعض
اليوم بتمشي في الشارع ما بتشوف مشاكل ما
بتشوف احد بيتخانق مع واحد علشان واحد
طالع فيه دقيقه في ناس لا لسه في مشاكل
لسه في ناس تكره المدرسه لسه يعني
انا ما شاء الله تبارك الله شايفكم غزيتوا
جميع القطاعات انتم الشباب وهذا الشيء
نتيجه ايش انكم تعلمتوا كويس ترا انا ما
ما اليوم انا في شركتي ترى ما عندي
محسوبيه في النواب احد اذا ما يكون كفوا
متالم والله ما اشغله واليوم ما شاء الله
تبارك الله اليوم ان يعني الناس اللي
رجعوا من البعثات ممكن اكثر من 230000
طالب وطالبه تراه هم اللي اليوم بيشغلوا
البلد مع رئيس برنامج همم
رئيس تنفيذ البرنامج جوله الحياه
وكان يعني يحكي عن مفهوم الحياه بانه
تاثيره الاساسي هو اييي في تاثير اقتصادي
انك انت تخلق قطاعات جديده ما هي موجوده
هذه القطاعات تسوي شركات هذه الشركات تسوي
وظائف تسوي مشتريات محليه وكل الاثار
الاقتصادي وفي اثر صحي الناس يعني حياه
فعليه الرياضيه انها تطلع تمشي في جده
في المطعم ياكل مثلا لانه الترفيه سابقا
هو عباره عن مطاعم بس مطاعم داخل الغرفه
مغلقه
في اثار صحي على على صحه الانسان وفي اثار
على موضوع السعاده لما الانسان بعد يوم
عمل طويل يروح
همم الموت لانه يمارس هوايه ولا يحضر عرض
ممتع هذه كلها جدد همم يعني نظره اليوم
حقه بدل ما هو يكون يوم روتيني
بس انا ودي اسمع منك ابو احمد على طيب بعد
ما تاسست الهيئه في 2016 وشو الي اختلف
عليك انت اليوم كواحد من اللي شغالين في
القطاع من يعني
يوم تاسست هيئه الترفيه من حسن حظي مازال
كان موجود موضوع مهرجان جده التاريخيه
الحين اختلف 180 درجه
اول شيء
اول شيء اني انا ما رحت راجعت 14 همم
دائره
[موسيقى]
انا تقدمت لهيئه الترفيه تمام بحكم انه
كان يعني
يعني
زعروني الناس اللي سووا استراتيجيه هذه
الترفيه فكان بالنسبه لهم هذا اول اول
ستريت
فيستيفالفير تمام
مهرجان بس يعني تم تغييره تمام وكان سمي
قالولي شوف لك اسم تمام
مهرجان اتاريك اللي جمع تريك
اول شيء الصراحه موضوع التصريح تقدمنا
تراجع 14
قلت انا ابغى اسوي مهرجان
جده التاريخيه تاريخ يوم كده
تمام جاني
برقيات منها
الامنيه تمام
ولا شافوني كلهم كلموني بتلفون ترى وصلتني
الموضوع منتهي الموضوع منتهي هذا هو الفرق
تغير همم الموضوع صار فيه عندنا مسرح طلع
احد غنى الموضوع انه هو فصل المجتمع رجال
نساء ما كان في
اشياء كثير تغيرت كثير تغيرت بالضبط في
خلال سته شهور وهذا اللي فات كله يعني انا
سويت مهرجان جد التاريخيه يمكن ماك اقل من
سنه كان ده كده وده كده
النسخه اللي قبل الهيئه ونسخه اللي بعد
نعم
كان اول دعم نتلقاه من من بعد بعد
كيف اثر الدعم هذا في حجم ولوحيه خلاني
ادخل في تقنيات اكثر مثل يعني عملنا دوم
وعملنا بروجيكشن على الدوم كان هذا اول
دوم يصير في السعوديه
البيوت التاريخيه همم همم يعني اعطاني دعم
اكثر
لاني انا استقطب همم اشياء يعني ما قد قد
ما كنت اقدر اجيبها من اول جبت فرق من بره
المختصه في موضوع الستريت فاستيفال
وسويت حفله غنائيه هناك وقتها مش حفله
غنائيه بس انا يعني جبت قدرت اجيب
الفنانين اللي هم يغنوا مش الشعبيين اللي
هم يعني همم الصغار لسه ما دخلنا في موضوع
الحفلات الغنائيه
كانوا جايين في القبه
ضوئيه بتتكلم عن تاريخ جدا من ايام
الفاطميه
الفنانين دول كنا كان عملنا مسرح زي
القارب وكنا نجيب فنانين صغار عشان يغنوا
الغنى
[موسيقى]
يلا تريتو يا هلا والله انا خالد القحطاني
وانا عبيد الله العيسى بدانا معكم مرتده
في البوت كاسي الرياضي اللي يحلل اهم
احداث الكره السعوديه كسبنا من خلال ثقتكم
وتفاعلكم والمركز الاول في كل حلقه الشيخ
خلانا نطمح بنا نتقدم خطوه
المونديال هو اكبر موسم دراما من يوم
انولدت الكوره قبل 150 سنه بدات في مسيرته
رونالدو
زين الدين زيدان
عشان كده قررنا ناخذ خطوه جديده ونكون
معكم صوت وصوره في مونديال 2022 الحدث
النادر في كل شيء تقريبا هذه اول مره يقام
في بلاد عربيه هذه ايضا اول مره يقام
بتوقيت هنا الشتوي والاهم من ذلك ان هذا
المونديال هو بمثابه الرقصه الاخيره
بلاعبين عظيمين جدا بقيمه كريستيانو
رونالدو وليونيل ميسي راح نحلل معكم افكار
مدربين ونقف فيه على كل جمله ورسم تكتيك
ولقد في شكلك اكبر مع منتخب الوطني اللي
بيشارك للمره السادسه واحنا نستمتع كلنا
جميعا باجواء مونديال 2022 في طريقتنا
اللي تعودتم عليها وحبيتها كوب قهوه
وسواليف بتحليل الدقيق وارقام مستدله
تابعونا في كاسده على قنوات 8 كما نصرت
البوتاس واليوتيوب
في 2017
سويته اول حفله موسيقيه للعوائل
صح وهذه ثقه انا يعني عمر خيرت اللي عمر
خيرت ثقه صراحه يعني انا سعيد فيها جدا
وفخور فيها باني انا رئيس الهيئه تمام
يعني الفكره جات مننا
يعني نحنا رئيس الهيئه اللي زكي الموضوع
شويه حساس انت هتقاعد الناس على طاوله
واحده
عائلتين مع بعض حتقدر
تقدم هذا هذا الخدمه
بشكل ان شاء الله ما يسيء الى سمعه بلدنا
قلت له يعني ان شاء الله وبتوفيق الله نحن
باذن الله هنقدر
فعمل طلبنا الترخيص حق
الموسيقار عمر خيرت وكانت اول مره السعودي
هو وزوجته يقعد مع شخص ما يعرف على طاوله
اول مره اول مره هذا 2017
والحمد لله
في مدينه الملك عبدالله
انباعت بالكامل والناس يعني خاضوا تجربه
جميله جدا كانوا يعني يسووها برا المملكه
في حياتهم ما سواها يعني انا بصراحه
الباب عشان اشوف الناس وهم طالعين واشوف
مدى سعادتهم ما في احد ما قال لي شكرا
يعني هذا الجانب المشرق طيب هل كان في
تحدي هل كان في مشكله في في تحليل التحدي
الوحيد انه مو انا كيف اسعد الزائر ما كان
في عندي اي تحدي او البيانو البيانو
عاد مو انا اللي اكلتها مسكين محمد ولدي
يعني نحن ما تصورنا انه البيانو بهذا
الحجم تمام ما جاء في بالهنا تصور الطياره
الوحيده اللي دخلت البيانو 3 3
كان الباب حقها ممكن يدخل فيه البيانو
يعني تعرف يعني مرينا بنايه لانه البيانو
وصل عمرك قبل الحفله يمكن بساعات يا رجل
ايه والله العظيم يعني ما تتصور
نحن جدا
[موسيقى]
الراعي اللي هو مدينه الملك عبد الله
السعوديه
تكلمنا على موضوع الهيئه برضو هذا فعليك
مدعومه نعم وش طبيعه الدعم هل هم يقولوا
لك خذ المبلغ هذا ورجع لنا ولا اخذها
مقابله خفض التذاكر ولا ايش الفكره
يعني الدعم انك انت تعمل فعاليه
بدون مردود
لانه كان الدعم مش كبير كانه مقاولات
يعني
الدعم اللي هو يخليك انك انت تعمل
الفعاليه بدون ما تروح تجري وراء الرعاه
واشياء زي كده لانه انت ترى فعاليه
يعني مشكوك في ربحتها يعني دعمهم يغطي كل
تكاليفك لا طبعا 50% تقريبا
للموضوع ده
ترى احتمال كبير انك انت تاكلها طيب انت
هنا تقول صولد داوت بعتها كلها كم تربح
فيها اااااه يعني تعرف ربحنا 100%
يعني شوفهم
يعني انا احمد الله ترى ترى
احنا جالسين يعني نكسب ملايين ترى ترى
تماما
الفعاليا الناجحه اللي على مستوى راقي
يليق من مكانه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
انا اتحدث انها تربي حاجتها
همم ما في بنيه تحتيه
الاي بيز نفس الرياله تي اي بيس همم غالي
غالي
يعني اليوم عمر خيرت عشان انا اجيبه ما
حدا بيجيب فلوس قليله وبعدين تنسي انه
نحنا
يعني الحمد لله ولله الحمد نحنا الجمهور
ترى نحنا الجمهور العربي نحن معروف من
ايام ما كنت اشتغل في الازياء
نحن دبجندر اليوم السعوديه السعوديه
طبعا انت عارف انه اقرب الازياء بعضها
تصنع في تركيا بعضها تصنع في الهند بعد ان
تصنع في المغرب تمام
كان في عنده مصنع في مصر
تخيل انه كل الخليج ياخذ من مصنع مصر
السعوديه ما تاخذ الا من ايطاليا
لانه نحن دقيق الشمندر
ولو اخذنا مثال هذه الحفله كم حققته فيها
حققنا تقريبا 10%
الاكبر طيب طيب وردت الفعل
في ناس ما احبه انكم تخلوا الناس
عند الناس خلاص
وتمام وتنكد عليهم
انا كمواطن سعودي انا جدا سعيد من بده
يصير في الترفيه لانه غير غير فكرنا غير
الفكر تماما صار الواحد يعني يغير فكر
يغير سياسته في حتى السفر انا اليوم والله
يا عمر انا اليوم استغرب ان الناس تسافر
ليش يعني
انت بتسافر
عشان حفلات موسيقيه نحنا جبنا لك كل الناس
في العالم ان كان انترناشونال وان كان عرب
وان كان خليجيين
في في على طريق الحفلات الغنائيه برضو
انتم سويتوا اول حفله غنائيه
مختلطه
اول حفله موسيقيه اول حفله غنائيه
كانت حفله تامر حسني
الكلمه صراحه مره كنت قاعد في المكتب جاني
محمد قال لي انا
بتفرج على
هلا فبراير نحن معروفين انه اهل الكويت
قال لي انا ما اشوف احد يتحرك
في الحفل
والله صحيح
قام قال لي ايش رايك خلينا نبحث ليش
فاتصلنا باخواننا اصدقاء لنا في الكويت
لقينا انه الترخيص في الكويت ممنوع الرقص
فيه
قلت له طيب لحظه خلينا نشوف ايش الترخيص
في الامارات
لقينا في الامارات
الترخيص يمنع الرقص بالزي الوطني
قال لي ايش رايك نحنا خلينا نكتب ممنوع
الرقص التمايل
فيقول هذه كانت
مره كبير وبدانا ننزل على وسائل الاعلام
تمام وصارت معايا مقابلات تلفزيونيه علشان
الموضوع ده
ااا يعني كان احتياطا لانه
طيب سويه حفله تامر حسني للشباب لانه خلاص
نحن اليوم
داخلين على قطاع الترفيه يعني نحن اليوم
داخلين على النقله
اللي هي النقله الطبيعيه عشان يصير ناس
طبيعيين زينا زي اي مكان اخر عشان لا يجيك
فرضا واحد يقول لك لا والله ما في حيل انا
زوجي هنا وانا هنا لانه هي كانت نساء رجال
نحن خلطناهم مع بعض
فالحمد لله الفاير باك هذا خلانا بالفعل
نعمل صولد اوت ان فورتي 5
منتج لدرجه الفنان ما صدق ما صدق انه نحن
في 45 دقيقه
وهذه حفله مدعومه من هيئه كانت مدعومه
يعني
بميزانيه اقل عشان يجربه
تمام بس كان فيها رعاه وكان فيه يعني شباك
كان كبير لانه تقريبا شهر 5 الاف 5 الاف
في 45 دقيقه في 45 دقيقه بتشارك ورد
موجوده على المنصه تمام
والله نعم
انا افتخر
بس برضو كان عندكم اجراءات معينه انتم
سويت خطه نحن عملنا
كممثل لا ابدا نحنا طال عمرك يعني نحنا
يعني بحكم خبراتنا الكبيره في اداره
الحشود تمام يعني نحنا في كل جون كان في
همم
منظمين كفايه تمام اول ان احنا سويته
نموذجين يطلعونه عشان يحطنا مو يعني مثال
بصراحه يعني في كل زول عملنا الحركه هذه
على اساس انه هو حتى الواحد لو فكر همم
نحاول قد ما نقدر
مساحه في الحركه عشان احنا دائما نفضل انه
انه يكون في ترقيم على الكراسي عشان لا
يصير في فوطه
سته يعني ما هذا الشيء مره فهذا الشيء
يساعدنا على ان احنا تنظيم الحركه داخل
المدرج مش في منطقه البي اي بي اه ابو
احمد طيب بعد الحفله هذه والنجاح ايش اللي
صار اااه صراحه يعني هذه هذه كلمه شكرا
لابنائي وبناتي اللي اللي اداروا الحفله
هذه لانه نحن حققنا نجاح مره كبير تمام ما
صار ابدا ابدا لله الحمد يعني الناس والله
يا اخي اقسم بالله انه المواطن السعودي
والجهود ترى يمشي ما هو عنيف
يعني نحن ال ال التمثيليه الي عملناها هذه
يعني كانت ضائعه وقت بالنسبه للناس ما
تتحركوا صراحه الحمد لله نحن تعلمنا منها
واثبتنا ولله الحمد وعتوها تمام انه الحمد
لله اليوم ترى تقدر تعمل حفلات تمام ما
فيها ااا رجال ونساء والحمد لله تكررت
بعدين السنه اللي بعدها 2019
اعاده التموضع النجوم
اللي طلعنا الحمد لله
كررنا الحفله مع نفس الفنان
وكانت يعني يمكن كمان يمكن في زياده في
الاعداد اكثر من السنه اللي قبلها
وكانت حفل مره ناجح وعملنا فيها فاير وركس
كمان اضافه
فخلصنا الحفله ومبسوطين وسعيدين رحنا رحنا
ننام انا والشباب ومحمد ولدي فجاه تعبان
مرهق مرهق يعني ترى انا ترى انا احب اشتغل
يعني انا ما يعني خلاص عندي اولادي اني
انا اقعد اسوي فيها كبير لا انا احب اقعد
فجعل الجوال بيتفجر تمام ما في حيل ارد
بعدين
جاتني رنه واتساب
واتساب يعني في مسجد فكيت المسج واحد راسل
لي تغريده
اعتز فيها جدا جدا لانه هذه كانت بالنسبه
لي هي هادي اكبر ربح للحفله واكبر ربح
سوته بنشماركيه تغريده مع المستشار تركي
ال الشيخ الله يحفظك يعني كتب فيها كلام
اثر الصدري لما قال هذه هي همم الحفله
همم هذه الحفله مشاركه وطنيه سعوديه
بايادي وطنيه اشكر الاخ زكي حسنين وابنه
محمد والسعودي مبدع في اي مجال يعني تواصل
مع
معالي المستشار لا والله نعم
طبعا انا كنت اتصلت على محمد قلت له ما رد
علي اتصلت على امراته قلت له قالت لي محمد
مغمى عليه قلت لها صحيه خليه يشوف
انا قفلت التليفون من هنا لقيت محمد عندي
في الغرفه ههه
المعالي المستشاره الوزير المسؤول
من ما تعرفه تمام ولا احد من طريقي ممكن
يوصلني له انه يتشكر مني كده هذا يعني
شهاده اعتز فيها جدا
قعدنا ما طار النوم والله العظيم بعد كده
شويه يعني تليفون تمام اااه
كان على الخط المستشار شكرنا وقال انا برا
المملكه ان شاء الله
بالفعل يعني كان عند وعده وصل الرياض
بعدها بشهر تقريبا اتصلوا بنا هيئه
الترفيه رحنا قابلنا معاه في مكتبه
وشكرنا واسنا علينا
وعدنا وعد كبير بان هو يكون داعم كبير لنا
في قطاع الحفلات الغنائيه
وعدنا انه نحن نصل الى العالميه وبصراحه
يعني
اشكره
بالفعل انا يعني يمكن ما وصلت العالميه بس
تراني ماني بعيد عنها بفضل دعممه
وثقته الكبيره والدعم طبعا في برنامج جود
الحياه همم مكتوب انه لا يزال قطاع
الترفيه متاخرا كثيرا عن المقاييس
المعياريه العالميه فهناك على سبيل المثال
سبع فعاليات فقط لكل مليون مواطن بالاضافه
الى السعوديه لا تمتلك صور خمسه اماكن
مخصصه الترفيه لكل مليون مواطن اي نصف ما
هو متوفر في المملكه المتحده احنا عندنا
شرح في البنيه التحتيه همم للفعاليات
الترفيهيه شو رايك اه طبعا هذا الكلام همم
صحيح 100% يعني اليوم همم في شو حكم مره
كبير في موضوع الدنيا التحتيه ااه همم
البلد محتاجه اماكن همم ترفيهيه ثابته
وهذا اللي الان بتعمل عليه همم شركه صله
الان همم الشيء يعني اليوم
يعني تخيل اليوم انا
بالنسبه لي بوليفارد الرياض هذا يعني هذا
مكان حي- هيعيش طول العمر سهل علينا امور
مره كثيره ان احنا اخذنا قطعه ارض بنينا
عليها مسرح دائم تمام سرنا بالنسبه لنا
الحفله اللي كنا نشيل همها
شهر عشان نسويها صرنا نسويها ثاني يوم
نطالب مننا نسوي حفله بكره نسوي حفله بكره
لانه ما شرحنا جاهز
مدرجنا موجود كنبنا موجود استيجنا موجود
الاضاءهتنا موجوده الموجود ال ال البنيه
التحتيه التحتيه هذه شيء مهم جدا اليوم
بلدنا كبيره
ومتراميه الاطراف تمام نحنا محتاجين اذا
نحن نكمل في موضوع الحفلات الغنائيه احنا
محتاجين مدينه زي الرياض محتاجه لاربعه
مسارح خمسه مسابح القطاع الخاص اذا هي
مجديه
لا يعني لانه تكلفتها جدا عاليه
يعني الاوبرا شوفها في العالم كلها بناتها
الدول
اليوم يعني نبغى اجابه ما هو بدوله ماسيه
ابو احمد
هو اكبر منافس في قطاع الترفيه والفعاليات
عنده ريتشارد اتيس في تنظيم المؤتمرات هو
ينظم
الحدث يعني اقتصادي في البلد وشركه تصلها
اللي هي تاخذ
كل الفعاليات في البلد وبعدين تروح تقسمها
على الاخرين تحس هذا مشهد صحي لقطاع
الترفيه
تبغاها بصراحه ايه ومن قلبي الحمد لله على
نعمه الله
كلام قوي هذا جدا واقول من القلب بدون اي
مجامله
وانتم تعتبروه تعتبروهم انه هم شركه
منافسه لي لا هم شركه سهله
تمام شركه دعمتها دعمها صندوق الاستماره
العامه يعني معناته انه هو صار عنده راس
مال كبير
لخدمه القطاع لانه سمو سيدي قال انه شركات
البيئه
في صالح البلد صالح المواطن اليوم دخول
صله في صندوق الاستثمارات العامه دراسه
المال الكبير عمل من صله شركه قد كده
كبرها موجود فيها كل شيء خبرات
على الارض خبرات داخل المكاتب عشان تفكر
وتعمل تعمل لنا مواسم سعوديه تمام وتعمل
الماستر بلان
لكل موسم هذا بيساعد كثير ما في شركه او
قطاع خاص ممكن انه هو يعمل هذا الشيء
ولما يعني نتكلم على قطاعه الترفيه اتذكر
صرف مع واحد والشباب قبل الحلقه اه كلمت
واحد عنده همم شركه صغيره
اكثر شيء انت مبسوط منه مش اكثر شيء انت
زعلانه منه قال لي اكثر شيء مبسوط منه انه
عندنا انقطاع قاعد يكبر يكبر بشكل ماكينه
فهذا يخلق فرص الجميع قلت له ايش اللي
مزعلك مزعلني انه هذا القطاع اللي يكبر بس
للكبار بمعنى مهما احاول على مركز
الفعاليات اخذ مناقصات ما في مناقصات تنزل
على صله بشمارك روتانا
والكبار هم يرجعوا يعطونا شويه من الكعكه
اذا راضين عنا لحاله طب ما انا كنت صغير
كيف كبرت كبرت الطموح بالعمل وبالاجتهاد
وبتوفيق الله سبحانه وتعالى
لهذا الشخص
ابدا انا اليوم يا سيدي الفاضل يعني اقول
لك اياها من يوم ما توصل عند مسرحي تمام
ترى شركه التي تستقبلك اليوم
بس تحت اشرافي اللي دخلك الباركينج شركه
تبعك هذه الشركات وطنيه سعوديه انا بتعامل
معاها اليوم ترى المعلومتك انا دوري مره
صار بروجيكت
اليوم نحنا
اللي يجيب لنا الاكل شركه اللي يجيب لنا
المويه شركه
اللي اللي بياخذ منه اللايك والساوند
والسكرين شركه بس ليش الاغاني
يعني هذا
بالنسبه لانه اليوم نحنا امتلكنا خبره مره
كبيره لانه روتانا هي يعني صاحبه السبق
روتانا هي اللي استثمر
كل جهوده ما قبل وبعد تمام ونحن الحمد لله
ربنا وفقنا وكسبنا كسبنا الثقه
من هيئه الترفيه فصار في عندنا ولله الحمد
تجربه جدا جميله
وموثوق فيها بس هذا ما هو ما هو صح مو
حقيقي اليوم يعني اليوم انت في مطاعم في
في حفلات غنائيه
اليوم اي شركه عندها الكفاءه والملائكه ان
هي تعمل بتاخد ترخيص من قال ترخيص ولو
نتكلم عشان اقفل بس المحور هذا وروح لمحور
الاخير لو بقفل واقول اذكر لي تشريع واحد
الان انت تنتظره وتنظيم
واذكر لي بنيه تحتيه او مرفق وانت تنتظر
الان اليوم كواحد من قاده القطاع هذا قال
لي لسه ينقصنا هذا التشريع والتنظيم والا
لسه ينقصنا هذا المبنى او هذه البنت
التحتيه
التشريع ما اعتقد من تظنين ولانو موجود
موجود
وما شاء الله تبارك الله يعني مجلس
الاقتصادي بيسبقنا في كل شيء
تمام
الحمد لله اليوم لو تشاهد
في مشاريع كبيره ترفيهيه تمام بتعملها
شركه صله وبتعملها الدوله تمام اليوم
الهيئه الملكيه لله الحمد لله المنتشره في
جميع انحاء المملكه كان في شمال المملكه
وفي جنبها وفي وسطها وفي غربها وفي
الشرقها هذه هتعمل على على على يعني في
جزء كبير منها اللي همم لقطاع الترفيه انا
متاكد لانه قطاع الترفيه هو انا اعتقد
ذراع قوي لبناء الاقتصاد لانه كل حاجه حلو
لو نبغى نسوي سياحه داخليه لو انا ما
بنجيب سياحه خارجيه لازم يكون في يكون
قطاع الترفيه موثوق فيه عشان انا اجيك
يعني انا اجيك من فرنسا ومن لندن ومن هنا
لازم يكون فيها في حاجه تجيبني اي نعم نحن
الحمد لله في عندنا ثوره سعره كبيره في
الاثار تمام ما يمتلكها ولا احد في الدول
الجوار الا يمكن مصر نقدر نقول
فهذا جذب مره كبير اليوم نحن عندنا شواطئ
ولله الحمد اجمل من اجمل الشواطئ والحمد
لله همم الدوله بتقيم مشروع البحر الاحمر
وامال عندنا بالنسبه للعلا اليوم مشروع
ضخم العلا اليوم همم هيكون في عندنا
استقطاب سياحي للمحبين الاثار بشكل مو
طبيعي اليوم عندنا اثار في كل احد فما
تروح في اثار
فجعل انا كاني كنت نايم وصحيت هذا عندنا
نعمه نعمه نحن في نعمه الله ان شاء الله
يديمها علينا ويبعد عنا الحساد بنتقل
لمجموعه من اسئله الاصدقاء واحمد همم
يعني ما هي غريبه عليك متعود عليها
ومثل الموضوع اسعار التذاكر يعني واحد
كاتب يقول همم خلينا نقول بالضبط تغريد
فهذا يقول عرض للاطفال وقلت تذكره ب 350
ريال عيب على صناعه الترفيه عندنا هذا
الكلام على حفل الاميرات ديزني اتبعكم
صحبا معرض الكتاب الطفل 350
معقول ابو احمد
من
اخر الدنيا اجيبه
طب انت عشان تروح يوري ديزني يبغالك تكلفه
قد ايه كبرى يعني الحمد لله نحنا جبنا لك
دزنا هنا ولا لا في الهوامش بالنسبه لكم
هنا ما زالت نفس اللي بتحكي عنه ال 10%
والخمسه
% ثق تماما اليوم ما اقدر اكذب ترى ورانا
ورانا مصلحه زكاه ورانا بس صدقني ترى ترى
يا رب 10%
النقطه الثانيه يا ابو احمد موضوع همم
الدخول القطع اليوم الشركات الناشئه لو في
واحد يعني
توصيعتك على قطاع اليوم صار فيه كبار
ماخذين المواقعهم كيف انا اقدر ادخل
واشارك في القطاع هل انت شايف فجاه معينه
تقول للشباب
كيف اوصل للحظه اليوم
اخر نفس ماركه او الحصه السوقيه اليوم
عندكم
للشباب انه القطاع هذا وعد تمام
تمام انت شايف نفسك انك انت مبدع في موضوع
اداره الحدود تخصص في هذا المجال تمام اين
تكبر وبعدين ممكن
تعمل حفله خاصه فيك او او بنت خاص بك
وتبيع التذاكر وخلاص يعني تحس نفسك انك
انت شارع شركه بتنظم فعاليات ترى يعني انت
قصه حياتي انا قلت لك اياها يعني بدانا من
فين وصلنا الى فين يعني احنا والدين لحظه
واحد همم يعني مسوي لكم منشن او يعني نسوي
لكم رد في نوفمبر 2021 على واحده من
الحفلات موسم سيء بشكل غير طبيعي
[موسيقى]
في ناس كثير على تجربه همم
بس عموما تجربه العميل عند همم في
السعوديه لا تزال
25 نوفمبر
الله يسامحك
ترى انا
تمام او اعوذ بالله من كلمه انا تمام انا
ترى رئيس مجلس اداره انا انسان عمري 61
سنه
تلاقيني واقف على الباب بانظم انا ولدي
وجميع العاملين ترى نحن معلومتك انا وعلمت
ولدي يعني نحن اللازم نقعد نلف على كل
المدرجات عشان نشوف ايش في مشكله عشان
نحلها
انا كل ساعه او كل نص ساعه لازم تلاقيني
بالف
واشوف
رائع بس لا يعني انه بالضروره ينتج تجربه
مميزه انا مثلا
تمام من يوم ما تدخل ارض
بنش مارك انت باذن الله تعالى عندك تجربه
تمام سعيده وانا احرص على هذا الشيء وانا
صدقني انا يعني الصغيره تزعلني انا اي شيء
صغير بالنسبه لي كبير بس ابو احمد
شخصيه هذا اخر نسخه بعض كتاب كنت احد
الضيوف المتحده
جدا
همم
اللي توصلوا معي
المنظمين ويعتقدرهم من شركه
ارسل رساله وبعدين اختفى طيب متى الساعه
كم انا بشارك ولا لا انتم متاكدين وين
ادخل
يقولوا يحاول اكلمك ما رديت طيب في واتساب
قاعدين نتراسل بعدين يعني محمد جزا الله
خير ما قصر يعني تولى الموضوع ترتبت
الامور بس اقصد تحدث هذه الاشاره انا مو
قاعد استخدمها اني اقول انتم سيئين يعني
للامانه سالت قالوا لي تجربه مسرح ابو بكر
سالم افضل من المسارح الاخرى اللي موجوده
على هذه بس اقصد انا انا اليوم واجهت تحدي
مع احد موظفينكم هذا طبيعي لانه عمل
البشري بس بشكل عام في السعوديه الاغلب في
فورمه الاول ولا في البوليفار ولا في معه
الكتاب في تجربه عميل لا تقيل التكلفه
اللي الواحد يتبعها الناس تسافر بره تدفع
ربع التكلفه هذه وتاخذ خدمه غير مفاجاه
انا ما اقول ان احنا الخدمه في اي بي ولا
عظيمه اللي بره بس ما فيها مفاجاه
الدول الاوروبيه انا قارنك بواحد يدفعني
مثل ما تدفعني همم في الدول العربيه انا
اتحدث ان احنا نمبر 1 في السعوديه مش انا
كمان
ما اعتقد انا حضرت يعني يمكن اعمل مهو انا
حضرت
ما حضرت انت تفاعليات في دول اخرى
تجربه اللي انت تقول الحمد لله على نعمه
البلد فانت تنفي ان تجربه العميل فيها
مشكله عندنا همم في لا يخلوه ولكن يعني
الكمان لله سبحانه وتعالى ولكن احنا
بنحاول مش ممكن
همم يعني انا تبغاني اتكلم عن نفسي واتكلم
على خيريه القطاع اتكلم عن القطاع انه
القطاع بيتحسن كثير كثير يعني كنا فين
وصلنا احنا اربع سنين
ترى خمسه سنين البلد تغيرت ترا الناس
اشتغل يعني ناس شغالين قرون وناس شغالين
20 سنه ترى اللي شغالين على 20 سنه نحنا
سويناه في خمس سنين وانا احمد الله على
النعمه ابو سلمان الله يحفظه
20 سنه خمسه سنين
ارجوكم قولوا شكرا كلكم
نحنا نشكركم
لانه ان شاء الله يكون نقد بناء لانه هذا
يزيد من اسرارناكم ونحن نوصل لرضاكم باذن
الله تعالى طالما انه في عندنا دعم كبير
اااه ولو بختم بموضوع
النتائج اللي وصلت لها اليوم بن شباركم
حدود 250 موظف همم
بسيط يمكن حدود
543 فعاليه همم
[موسيقى]
43 مشروع قيمه المشاريع 400 مليون دولار
اللهم زد وبارك
اقول خليني اقوى سويسرا ههه
450 مليون دولار بروح اصيف من بدري ههه
ايش اكثر انجاز
تفتخر فيه بعد هذا الرحله
الاشياء اللي حلمت فيها وصلت لها مثل
يعني
همم
يعني اقرب شيء نقدر نقول عليه انه هو انا
الحمد لله احد اهم الشركات اللي تعمل في
قطاع الحفلات الغنائيه
انا كنت احلم اني انا اخذت لك اداره حشود
فمعرض اليوم انا قدرت معرض من الالف الى
الياء
واشير اليه بالبنان لله الحمد
وان شاء الله نقول يا رب يا رب يا رب انت
انسان مطلع ما شاء الله في الاعلام يعني
نقدر نقول واحد في المئه همم الناس ما
انبسطوا ولا كيف بتعطيني
موضوع الدخول للخروج يعني هذه اشياء الحمد
لله اليوم باقول لك اني انا بحقق حلم حلم
لي اللي انا اسوي منتدى الرياضه الاقتصادي
باقي حلو
ايش الحلم القادم
هذا الحلم
المقابله ثانيه
الرحله التاريخيه لقطاع الترفيه على لسانك
وعلى على لسان تجربه شكرا ابو احمد على
قبول الدعوه انا اشكرك من اعماق قلبي لانه
انت اليوم خليتني اعمل سيره الذاتيه
تستاهل الله يعطيك العافيه شكرا يا ابو
احمد شكرا لك شكرا لكم شكرا
في الكاميرات في تسجيل الصوت عبد العزيز
المسجد وفي التحرير انا خليل وفي الهندسه
الصوتيه محمد الحسن وفي الاشراف على
الانتاج اصيل فقط
احد المنتجات شركه ثمانيه للنشر والتوزيع
[موسيقى]